[Music]
so this put icaru in crisis
down one game with a must-win situation
with the black pieces against magnus
carlsen
and now we are going to get down to the
business of analyzing the second game
which of course was no less interesting
than the first although it took on
very different contours let's see
uh it was a king's indian now i have a
psychological riddle for you guys
i have a psychological riddle for you
guys now
e5 here those of you who play the king's
indian or even have a nodding
acquaintance with it will know that e5
is the main move
hikaru plays knight pd7 first which is
something that i do pretty often against
certain opponents
can anybody tell me why hikaru
switched up the move order in this
fashion
why didn't he play the main movie five
and it wasn't because he wanted to avoid
theory or anything
easy question but it's important to get
the pulse on
the psychological subcurrent of the game
yeah so magnus of course could have and
would have played the exchange variation
magnus would have played the exchange
variation and this line is known for its
straws tendencies magnus would never
lose such a position
ever um i actually hate
allowing the exchange variation so i
myself very frequently play them in ipd7
now white has the extra option of going
e5 here but
this is known not to be good after ded i
think
i think the move knight g4 is possible
here i analyze this at some point
and the f file opens to black's
advantage into white's detriment
and black is totally fine here it's a
double-edged position exactly the kind
of car
would want and this is what makes the
king's indian so great it's one of the
only openings
against which you can almost guarantee a
fighting game you can
guarantee winning chances because there
is no way to play one of those
simplifying lines
so knight bd7 is the old classical line
i play this move quite a bit the main
line
is knight c6 that is by far the main
line the modern mainline ipd7 is the old
main line
but there is nothing wrong with it i
talked about this uh yesterday
how fashion and chess works i think much
like fashion in the clothing industry
it's not like
people wear certain types of clothes and
then it's all of a sudden discover
that this type of clothes cause cancer
or
raise your risk of some sort of disease
it's just that
fashions change and the cool kids wear
something else
and you know it's no longer cool to walk
around and bose headphones you know
people not walking around beats
headphones or vice versa
oceania is at war with europa and then
europa's award with oceania you know
so it's not that these openings have
been refuted
which is a paradox because you might
think that they have this opening hasn't
been refuted this line is in perfectly
good standing
as you can see magnus was not able to
crack this line
i just want you guys to be aware of that
that's just my opinion
but it's very interesting to observe how
fashions change
and most of the time it's not that an
opening is refuted it's just that
again the cool kids start playing
something else they get bored of the
lines that were once extremely
fashionable um
how do you personally know it well you
just watch the top games and you see
what people play you know it used to be
the berlin
the berlin has slightly fallen out of
fashion i think people have gotten bored
of it now it's the italian
it used to be the night off a couple
years ago the grunfeld it really changes
almost from tournament to tournament
sometimes that was a 1984 reference
thank you for catching that
one probably my favorite book so bishop
e3 knight g4 again we'll go fat this is
all fury
h5 now what is the idea of the move h5
is magnus uh
sorry is icaru creating a threat with
this move what what is the purpose of
this weird move
h5 like let's say white locks up the
center with d5
as dikaio correctly points out g5
followed by h4 very important to point
out the fact that this knight is
undefended doesn't help
if white takes on h4 and tries to open
up the attack on the knight
then black plays g takes h4 bishop g4
hg3
and black emerges up a piece now i've
played this
myself many many times i've played this
particular move before i've had this
position on the board
and h3 follows followed by bishop g3
what's the purpose of h3 not only to
chase the knight away to an awkward
square but to open up the h2 score for
the bishop
now when you plug this position into the
computer and i just turned on the
computer on chess.com
it gives approximately an evaluation of
plus 1.2
uh to plus 1.5 and i believe that the
beauty
of the king's indian one of the most
amazing aspects of the king's indian
is that it's an opening that even modern
computers have still not wrapped their
head around because
white has such a vast space advantage
and
there are certain i guess algorithmic
properties
that make the computer despise the
king's indian and i speak of this
universally stockfish houdini every
computer has always hated the king's
indian
and i don't know exactly why that's the
case but i don't believe
that this evaluation is accurate now
there's no doubt that white is better
white is objectively better in these
positions without a doubt
but because black is attacking the queen
the king and white is attacking the
queen
or sorry what is the tactic on the queen
side that lends
tremendous appeal to the king's indian
as a distinctly human
opening i think the king's indian might
be one of the first openings to be
refuted
when chess is solved but it's going to
be one of the last openings
um to go out of fashion because
for a human to play the king's indian
properly with white
is as we could see even for magnus in
extremely tall order
okay leela i don't know
do you guys want to find out while dilla
thinks about it i can turn lon lila
i have lila in chess base we can take a
look
but i think leela also dislikes it um
let's take a look at what leela thinks
let's take a look at what leela thinks
now give me a second to open up chess
space and i have to share a new scene
with you guys
now first let's take a look at whether
this position has occurred before
using the reference feature on chess
space cross matches this position you
can see very popular line
362 games now my database is not quite
updated so
some of the recent games the last couple
of months might not have made it
now we see the 38 games bishop g3 two
games
and it's transposed into a position
rajab played it against roy's in 2010
king h7
so we are still following the gamer job
of queen c2 was the novelty
queen c2 was the novelty now let's take
a look at what lila
thinks about this sometimes lila makes
my computer freeze so i warn you guys
now leela is slower i think because it
uses gpu
so we need to give it a second now you
can see stockfish here on depth 32
you guys don't see it because it's
obscured oh leela is obscured
okay so you can see that uh according to
leela
actually leela leela
uh does not give as big of an advantage
for white as stockfish let's compare
let's see if we can add both at the same
time my computer will not have a
meltdown
let's see if my computer will not have a
meltdown this is very interesting i
always like to compare
and contrast so
it might be a little bit small for you
guys to see but you should see and it's
cut off just a tad
it's cut off just a tad but you see plus
minus look at the huge difference in
evaluation
almost one point stockfish you guys
should be able to see plus 1.39
and the depth is quite low but leela
is actually very moderate is very
moderate in its assessment
um amazing amazing uh it's always
interesting to compare
when you see these things so let's now
continue the game we won't see the
notation but
i want you guys to find some moves so
this is clean this is clean and this is
going to be good now
c6 covers the d5 square k rook 81
x-raying the queen fine hicario plays
queen e7 and this is the critical moment
i think this is what
lost magnus the game actually i think
this is what lost magnus the game this
move
now i think magnus got a little bit
impatient here and he tried to break
through too early
before the position demanded it and
the the dot is just means white to move
now he played c5 we'll talk about the
move in a second i think he should have
played probably b4
and i think he should have prepared the
move c5 this is generally what is very
annoying in the king's indian and
probably hikaru
maybe would have considered something to
the effect of f5
and you get a bit of a wild position but
i'm quite sure that
that uh white's got to be better here i
mean normally these things they fall
apart pretty fast
so i would have played b4 here but
magnus goes c5 immediately and it's a
positional sacrifice d takes c5 d5
which should be intuitively clear to you
guys he's breaking through he's
establishing a very strong pass pawn
and on c takes d5 he's going to
establish a monster knight on t5
so from a i mean from a
purely positional standpoint i
understand the idea
the problem is that i think what he
didn't fully
appreciate is the fact that hikaru
doesn't have to take on d5
now could you explain this to me guys
why is ikaru
not afraid of okay carl plays knight b6
here
okay why is he not afraid conceptually
speaking
of magnus pushing the pawn up to d6
why isn't this scary like because this
move looks very scary but it isn't
and where should the queen go because
there's a small trap for the
higher rated players among you try to
determine where the queen should go here
yeah so everything that you guys are
saying so far is correct you can
blockade it there's nothing to support
it so
you shouldn't be afraid of past pawns
just intrinsically
if you go queen e8 for example you're
going to go bishop e6 you're going to go
rook d8
and this knight on h6 is going to be
delegated to f7
and it's just going to pick the spawn
off dikaio says queen d7 now i would
caution you against using the queen as a
blockader
now why is it bad to use the queen as a
blockade there's a couple of reasons
not to pick on yudikai but i think it's
a very instructive mistake
first of all look at this knight on b6 i
immediately see that it's out of squares
so the idea of a4 um okay i love picking
on you let me be clear
threatens a5 which drops the knight and
if you go a5 here then the knight has
lost its support
aaron nimsovich in his book my system
pointed out that the queen is usually a
bad blockader
and the reason the queen is a bad
blockader is simply because you want to
consign it for more important tasks when
it blockades something
it greatly reduces its mobility so you
would want either the knight or the
bishop blockading this pawn
now the move queen f7 here is a small
tactical blunder
could somebody tell me why that's the
case why is this move a small tactical
blunder
yeah d8 or or or e8 i would say d8 or e8
but not f7 not queen f7
yes the knight is blocked that is true
conceptually speaking but why is this
actually a tactical mistake
why is this a tactical mistake correct
bishop takes c5
bishop takes c5 the pawn is overloaded
you have to immediately see
the potential forkable square knight to
g5
and after f takes c5 knight g5 check
well
it's a fork image so we lose a very
important central pawn so queen e8 would
be good here
so with that being not possible magnus
is reduced to taking on c6
and although it is true that black's
pawn structure is
quite damaged here i want you guys to
notice
at this point that hikaru already has a
stronghold
on the e force on the d4 square can you
imagine
how scary it's going to be for white if
one of black's knights
eventually lands on day four i mean can
you see how scary that's gonna bite
how do you hear that's gonna be now
that's not very far from reality black's
only a couple of moves away
from putting a knight on d4 and so this
is why i always advocate to my students
among other things
a very flexible approach to pawn
structure because
on the one hand the pawn structure could
be visually unappealing
but on the other hand it could be
responsible for
fortresses and this spawn is responsible
for guarding these two squares
so even though these pawns are
optically unappealing they are
performing both of them
very important duties despite the fact
that they're stacked on top of each
other
okay hikaru plays rook ba very strong
move
and another reason these pawns are great
is because you can give one of them up
hey brija
and you will have the other one still on
the c
file you're attacking the pawn
and black is also preparing to go to b4
so magnus defends the pawn rook before
follows
magnus says nothing better than to take
this one to ichikara responds bishop b7
attacking the queen by extension
attacking the e4 pawn and after queen d7
of course icaru could have taken the
queen but why allow
why allow white's rook to get on the
seventh rank
so can we essentially force the queen
trade but without
allowing white truck on the seventh rank
what do you guys
what can you guys come up with in this
position now i know some of you saw the
game
but what can you guys come up with here
but let's compel white into it queen f7
would be
too passive rook f7 is correct rook f7
is very nice
because you're attacking the queen
you're forcing the trade and now
this pawn is lost this pawn is attacked
twice
and i was gonna say defended nuns
defended zero times
magnus decides to at least get black's
bishop four which is very much sensible
and guess what happens guys
remember
remember that far away time when i
mentioned the d4 square
well guess freaking what look at this
beaut
look at this monster on d4 monster on d4
look at this knight on h6 it was
excommunicated for a while
but guess where it can go now now that
the pawn has been eliminated from e4 and
we update our perception of the position
we see that the knight is a beautiful
path toward the center with knight f5
not only is magnus upon up but black is
the one who has the compensation as they
say
well i like this move i don't know i
don't i don't hikara said it was a
mistake well
maybe he thought knight f5 should have
been preferred
maybe he thought knight f5 should have
been preferred and in that case it's the
same idea
i don't know i i thought knight f5 there
might be bishop d3
but again let's not be too influenced by
what the computer is saying i think from
a human perspective it's a very strong
move
f3 by magnus trying to involve his
bishop on f2 and i think this position
rook a1 he doesn't want to trade
obviously
i i believe that this was the critical
position in the whole game this one he
carved the game
even though there was 50 more moves of
intrigue and don't worry we won't look
at all 50.
um i won't bore you guys for two hours
but
i hope you guys are having as much fun
as i am unpacking this game i know this
is not as tactical of a game as the
previous one
but i think it's still very fun to put
ourselves in the shoes of these players
and really squeeze the marrow
um out of this i'm on the east coast
yeah
i'm in i'm in charlotte by the way
kotojo so i am up at 4am
now what's going on here well
here's the problem problem is that if we
move our rook to d2 white's gonna take
on c5
now you might be like big [ __ ] well we
put a rook on d2 this isn't this great
this isn't great because white can go
rook f2 and neutralize the rook and
notice the pawn majority you really
don't want to give
your opponent a chance to quickly create
a pass pawn and that is exactly
what black is doing here this pawn will
appear on b6 before you can even blink
and black doesn't have that much play on
the king side so we certainly don't want
to give the spot up
but if we don't give this pot up then
aren't we going to lose the exchange
and this is where hikaru really stepped
up to the plate
uh the move that he played is i think
positionally brilliant i don't think
it's that hard to understand
once you get to the bottom of it hikaru
plays the move bishop h6 activating his
bishop
taking under control e3 square now why
the hell is he not afraid of magnus
taking on d4 who would like to attempt a
conceptual explanation
of why this is good for black i'm asking
a difficult question for you guys
um but i think you guys can tackle this
why is this exchange sacrifice not only
justified
but essentially devastating and magnus
does take the exchange on the next move
now first of all you have a past pawn
first of all you have a pass plan test
bonds are important especially the
connected one second of all
as guy romiti says
look at the weak dark squares around
black's king that could actually lead to
either checkmate
or the win of material and why cannot
solve the problem with dark squares
because white has just given up
white has just given up as dark square
bishop dikaio points out as well
that black is controlling the center
black is a huge pawn chain in the center
and i would also point out that black
every single piece
is participating in the game now white
can go bishop e6 bishop f5 but now the
knight would be replaced
by these snappers and e4 is just going
to be devastating black's gonna create
connected passers
and the game is essentially gonna be
over rooks are not that good
at stopping past pawns in front of them
as you guys probably know rooks
belong usually behind pass pawns and
with the rooks being as passive as they
are and the only lifeline
the only lifeline toward activating the
rooks and putting them behind the pawn
well guess what that lifeline is taken
away by black's bishop which is
permanently controlling the c1 square
neither is rook f2 possible with the
idea of rook c2
because of the simple bishop e3 it's
almost like watching leonel messi play
soccer and feeling that there's 15 men
on the field rather than 11 or
watching lebron james play basketball
and feeling there's eight basketball
players on a team rather than five
when your pieces are harmonious and
active like this it almost feels like
there are more pieces
even though material is equal or even
the opponent is of material
um in any case not that i watch messi
that often but i do enjoy
some of his games okay magnus
plays rook f1 bishop d2 and here he
acquiesces
to the inevitable because if he doesn't
take the rook then black has all the
advantage to the position at least he
might suffer for an exchange
rookie rook d1 bishop e3 check king h2
now a very strong positional move
uh h4 and the idea of h4
is to cement black's control
over the dark squares now you wouldn't
want to allow
uh the potential of white playing the
move g4 which might lead which might
might lead
which might slightly liberate himself so
h4 just
you know cements black's control over
all these squares magnus plays b4 we'll
go through the next stage of the game
relatively quickly because
there's a lot of tactical complications
here um
i know that hikaru made several
inaccuracies and he could have won the
game faster i know that magnus procured
serious strong chances i think that's
less important than
understanding the arc of the game and i
will leave that task largely to you guys
if you want to kind of
get your hands dirty and plunge in
that's totally to be encouraged but
since i don't have a computer
at hand i won't attempt the daunting
task
man now i sound like anthony falcon
jesus and before i know it i sound like
anthony fauci
rook d4
rook c7 checking h6 now it looks like it
looks like
uh white's completely winning i i'm
telling you not to wear masks
so it looks like black is completely
winning
um but in reality
this position is harder to win than it
seems magnus finds a very strong
defensive resource rook d7
soon i'm going to look it look like give
me a couple years
and if d2 now i can't get that out of my
mind i feel like i'm
yeah so he takes d4 bishop a4
and all of a sudden the pawn is stopped
and remember guys
white has a pawn majority on the queen
side so you can't sleep on that
this pass pawn is going to be created
very quickly so hikaru decides to
eliminate
this pawn but he gives up the pride of
his position now he still has
obviously tremendous
tremendous um play on the king side he's
got all of his pieces playing
he's almost got a mating attack and he
forces white into total passivity
he retools his pieces so the knight
comes back to f5
opening up the square for the bishop
he's also indirectly defending this pawn
because bishop e3 check wins the rook
and well he he
basically keeps attacking keeps
attacking
and eventually well he takes another
pawn
and eventually he wins the exchange back
and we get this end game which i think
i'm not sure you guys probably know this
because in the official broadcast
they probably analyzed this end game to
death and i'm sure it's already been
determined whether it's winning or drawn
i have the feeling that it's a draw with
best play but
with no time on the clock deciding
where you're going to put the king are
you going to put it here or here or here
is almost impossible so it's one of
those things where you got to be very
careful about just looking at the
computer assessment
now here hikaru potentially had to move
f5 check
with the idea of g5 checkmate can't
sleep on mates
but um but your king takes f5 so
i guess f5 is rash kicaro brings his
rook here
and how did he win this game well
eventually he basically put white and
zug's won
i think he put white and zuma that's the
whole point
because now the king would like to
remain on e4
now here's what interests me now why did
magnus
not keep his king on g2
how would hikaru have made progress here
would be my main question
how would he karo made progress here
because here's the thing guys
as soon as the king departs from these
pawns
white's going to take this opportunity
to go rook of fate
and rook takes f6 check and this is a
dead draw
this is a dead draw so
i'm not sure off the top of my head
what it was that magnus was scared here
f5 king f2
perhaps you can check him and go king f4
something to this effect
and perhaps something to this effect is
actually winning
i don't know i'm not too too interested
in this right now perhaps we will
separately take a look at the end game
so king c6 here you're saying is a draw
king c6
g5 king b7 f5 of course i understand why
magnus was scared of this
but rick of fate rook of fate
this is a draw this has to be a drug
because g4 is a very famous draw this
this structure this structure is very
famously a draw and i'm sure magnus
knows this because
what eventually happens is that even if
the king doesn't first of all now
black has to be careful but what
basically happens is and
of course this is also a draw this is
just a draw but why doesn't even need
that even without the king it's a draw
because
at this moment what white does
is he basically chases the king and as
soon as it goes to f1 you go to h8
if it moves to e2 you go to e8 you
attack that pawn until the king stands
in front of it and then you attack the
other
one and then even with the pawn on h3
very famously
there's nothing that can be done here